[Music]
tonight Governor Rick Scott filed a
lawsuit against Palm Beach and Broward
counties for lack of access to public
records regarding voting numbers this
comes as a recount now looms over his
race for the US Senate joining us now
the man himself Governor Rick Scott
governor I'm looking at these numbers on
election day you're up 57,000 votes
what is it number now now it's down to
15,000 votes so it gets clear we got
some left wing after to activists we've
got some Democratic DC lawyers they're
down here for one purpose to steal this
election some help there our County
Supervisor I looked at the numbers you
were told five different numbers Florida
law says that all absentee early voting
numbers must be reported in within 30
minutes of the polls closing correct
absolutely
and those drums they found seven to
eight thousand votes Sean they found 78
thousand new votes since election day
two days ago in Broward County and
15,000 more votes in Palm Beach we don't
know how many more votes they're going
to come up with but this sure appears
they're gonna keep finding as many votes
as it takes to try to win this election
right
so we I've asked the four department law
enforcement to immediately do an
investigation we filed lawsuits we're
gonna fight this and we're gonna win
well this she in 2016 our office posted
results a half hour before the polls
closed that's a election violation law
but broken she was sued for leaving
amendments off the ballots she also in
the case of Debbie wasserman-schultz
why is this person even working there
well what I've done is I've asked for an
investigation but we've had we have
examples there's the Palm Beach super
supervisor won't allow normal party
officials that are supposed to be
reviewing ballots they're not allowing
them to do it properly that's a
violation of the law they were supposed
to report all these results they're not
but how did they come up with 78,000
more votes you just didn't in Broward
than 15 and Palm Beach no other counties
having these problems we had a we had a
horrible hurricane
in the Panhandle it didn't happen there
the lawyers that come down said they're
not here to do they're here to win the
election not here to say oh I want to
find out what the what the results are
and make sure those fair results they
get down here for 100 women and they've
said that when they election 27 days ago
the Panhandle was smashed with a one of
the worst hurricanes we've seen they got
their votes in on time they ended up
doing this I cannot to me this is the
single biggest abuse of power in an
election I've seen and they have mark
Elias the guy at the heart of the whole
Perkins Kui Fusion GPS Clinton bought
and paid for dossier leading the way yep
they they're down here he's down here
for one purpose still this election and
he said he's down here just to win this
election he doesn't care about anything
else down there to win so we won yeah
we won we're I'm going to be the US
senator I'm gonna fight this all the way
we're gonna do everything we can we're
looking at every legal remedy we can we
can exercise we're gonna fight this and
we're gonna win this this is County
except Broward and Palm Beach did it the
right way every other County and they've
done this before and she ever did she
still have a job
well she's separately elected in these
counties and the good thing about some
of these other Supervisors that did the
right where Democrats also so every
other County Republican or Democrat
those supervisors did the right way
these two didn't they have violated the
law where we're going I've asked the
floor of law enforcement to do
investigation and we're and we've always
filed lawsuit we're gonna make sure we
win this I won this election for the
benefit of the people this state their
will is not going to be throated I've
never seen anything like this in my life
it is obviously corrupt obviously laws
were broken obviously they're
shenanigans here I believe you and
senator Rubio are 100% correct we will
follow this every single second of every
day now because the people of Florida
deserve their just vote which they got
it and you won this race hands down and
this is a this is a disgrace that they
get to do this election in election out
somebody needs to go to jail here if
this keeps happening you keep violating
the law
you don't respond every other County
responds then you change your numbers
again and again and again
something's not right all right governor
thank you